When threatened the Hairy frog acts like wolverine
from X-men.
It's able to break the bones of its toes and
protrude them out of its skin to act as claws.
WHAT THE FAK
The Facts and knowledge on Animal Defenses
The Pangolin looks like an anteater covered
in scales and is found across Asia and Sub
Saharan Africa.
When in danger it curls into a small ball,
protecting its defenseless underbelly, using
the scales to create an impenetrable shield
around them, that looks similar to an artichoke
or pinecone.
The scales are sharp around the edge, creating
an added line of defense when attacked.
They're made of keratin, just like the hair,
skin, and nails of humans.
They are one of the most endangered groups
of mammals in the world as they are considered
a delicacy in certain parts of the world.
STOP EATING THEM - THEYRE AWESOME.
The Pistol shrimp has the ultimate hand gun.
One of its claws is about half the size of
its entire body, and that claw packs a powerful
weapon.
When in danger or hunting prey the Pistol
shrimp is able to snap it's claw shut so quickly
it ejects a jet of water that travels 60 MPH
and the sound of the snap is 218 decibels.
A bubble is formed behind the stream of water
called a cavitation bubble that implodes and
creates a flash of light and temperatures
close to the temperature of the surface of
the sun.
This jet of water and bubble stun predators
and fish and easily kills them at close range,
which the Pistol shrimp then carries into
burrow to feed on.
The pistol shrimps snapping has even been
known to interfere with the sonar of submarines.
The Bombardier beetle basically shoots napalm
at enemies.
They live at soil level, making them a constant
target for ants to prey on.
The time it takes to unfurl their wings from
under the wing covers is slower than most
insects and can cost them their lives.
So they've developed a defense mechanism to
buy enough time to fly away.
They produce diverse toxins like acid, aldehydes,
phenols, and quinones in sacs next to their
abdomen and they aim and shoot the liquids
in the form of a spray.
The spray is ejected at 100 degrees Celsius.
This is caused by the explosion generated
at the moment of ejection by the mixing of
the chemicals.
Hagfish have the ability to create massive
amounts of slime in order to suffocate their
predators.
It turns the water around the enemy into a
gelatinous goo that clogs their gills and
chokes them.
They also have the ability to tie themselves
into a knot and slide in and out of it.
This helps when escaping predators and also
cleans themselves of their own slime.
If that doesn't work they have the ability
to sneeze and unclog their nostrils of slime.
The mimic octopus was discovered in 1998 in
Indonesia and has the ability to mimic other
sea life in order to defend itself from predators.
Scientists have seen it imitate the sole fish,
a flat poisonous fish, the Lion fish that
hovers above the sea floor and has poisonous
fins, and the sea snake which is very toxic.
They have seen the octopus change into various
other shapes but are not exactly sure what
they are emulating, but they assume they can
take the shape of sand anemones, stingrays,
mantis shrimp, and jelly fish.
The octopi are able to figure out what creature
to change into depending on the predator and
its surroundings.
The boxer crab has a symbiotic relationship
with their boxing glove hands made of sea
anemones.
They attach the anemones to the ends of their
claws and use them as defense against predators
because of their stinging power.
The crabs often wipe the anemones along the
sea bed to collect food particles which it
then removes with its mouth.
In return the anemones get to feast on the
particles of food the crab leaves behind while
feeding.
The goblin shark is one of the most unusual
looking creatures in the sea.
Very little is known about this particular
species of shark but it lives in the very
deep waters around 4000 feet deep and in many
different seas around the world.
They were first discovered in the waters around
Japan.
The goblin shark hunts by sensing the presence
of prey by electro sensitive organs in the
snout.
Once it finds its prey the shark is able to
protrude it's lower jaw and uses it tongue
like muscle to suck the prey into it's sharp
front teeth.
I'm gonna leave you with this creature.
What is it and how does it escape its predators?
Before we go here's last video's winner.
Be sure to subscribe for more Vsauce2 and
as always - thanks for watching.